let's talk about uh collapse
so you said uh you just mentioned soviet
union collapses just after afghanistan
yes
we are uh an empire of sorts right
so we've become an empire yes so is
afghanistan going to be our demise
do you think
i think that unless working class people
step up and look at what's happening in
the rio grande valley if working class
people step up and say no more not my
kids not my money we're going to take
we're going to take charge of this we're
going to get back to some basic
fundamentals and we're not going to
retreat into fortress america i'm not a
retreat sports america we've got to have
we we will be throughout the world right
but not like we are today in everybody's
business spread out all over hell's half
acre sticking our nose in everywhere we
will be and we have to confront the the
existential threat which is the chinese
communist party okay we have to do that
and by the way i've said and their
philosophy is unconventional warfare
right the the the the
you have economic and cyber you have you
have information in cyber and economic
right
then you have kinetic we are hurtling
towards kinetic war in the south china
sea and taiwan even as we speak so i
want to bring up this uh tweet from elon
musk that we saw earlier
daily mail says elon musk posts cryptic
tweet about the quote son of the old
world setting in a dying blaze of
splendor
he tweeted the guns of august it's a
book um
about the early stages of world war one
he followed up with a tweet with a lord
of the rings reference he's not
responded to comments about what he
meant
but
he said nine rings for mortal men
following afterward after he said uh
well the guns of august are very
prophetic i mean the the following quote
was one of the guys trying to negotiate
a piece to make sure we didn't go to war
was
said the lights of europe are going to
go out never to be relent in my lifetime
remember 1914 what happened with the
assassination in serbia in late july
excuse me late june
basically five weeks later
they they had these treaties
in the in the in the mobilization it
kind of took on a life of zone and
inexorably were drawn to a war
from august of 1914 that war did not end
until the fall of the berlin wall that's
why the 20th century is the most bloody
century of mankind's history when they
look back and we lived it you in this
audience were
some of you
were born in what will be called a
modern dark age
250 million people died were slaughtered
in the 20th century through war
starvation of of what happened in august
of that's why the guns of august
who wants to read barbara tuchman's book
will see when the experts when the
experts know everything remember europe
was a hundred years of peace since
napoleon was finished it was a great
industrial remember the steam engine we
exploded on industrial production
everything the wealthiest the world's
ever been the most trade the world's
ever been the most united the world's
ever been a globalized system the world
it created the victorian values cratered
before our eyes into a sea of barbarity
okay
that ended with you know the camera
rouge and in in mao se tang and all that
and eventually afghanistan which brought
down the soviet empire and eventually to
the berlin wall that from 1914 to 1989
the bloodiest the short 20th centuries
as bloodiest century in mankind's
history and elon musk who's a smart guy
i think is sitting there is this is this
new globalization order is it going to
be is is is afghanistan
is that the guns of august in other
words is that the is that the
assassination in serbia that leads the
dominoes to and quite frankly
people ought to be very concerned and
right now you should be cutting off the
football and cutting off the baseball
you should be watching the news you
should be thinking what is going on here
what is going to change in my life
what's going to change in my children's
lives right have you been tracking the
food shortages
pretty uh pretty scary yeah
uh
how does it affect you a lot of people
might not notice it depending on what i
think a lot of people might be noticing
you go to taco bell for instance and
they got a sign up saying we don't have
these food items you go to starbucks and
say we don't have these food items my uh
uh i'm trying to order uh food for for
my pets and they're like
this is out this can't be bought went to
the pet store and it was like 50 bucks
for cat food yeah it's getting harder
and harder to to uh secure and supply
these things you know combined with
those
we've had the greatest increase in in
prices i think in 50 years right right
it's not trans story the federal reserve
says oh it's all transitory no don't
worry about it what ain't transitory
particularly working class you're
getting eaten alive we knew it wasn't
those of us who have been tracking this
i'm sure you knew that these prices
would stay up the idea that oh don't
worry it's just playing catch your
betters you know you say that but your
bettors the governors of the federal
reserve all the economists they sat
there two months a month ago and said no
you're wrong tim
this is transitory right it's just a
slight blip lying everything's fine
you're not an expert go back in your
cave go back and shut up and sit down
pay your taxes put your pension money in
that'll go that'll grease the system
we'll control all the assets and you're
gonna pay us rents because you're gonna
pay the carrying cost this is one of the
reasons i
got out of the cities you know i lived
in uh i lived in new york and then there
was protests and things were getting bad
and then some cops got assassinated in
front of my apartment over on myrtle and
nostrand right around there uh tompkins
i think it was and so i said you know
maybe it was political it was it was a
black nationalist killing cops he said
you take two of ours we take two of
yours and so i said maybe i shouldn't
live in this city because you know i've
already seen the protests and i see the
escalation happening before my eyes i
move over to the jersey side i'm like
you know i'll still work in the city but
i'll stay out of the the density of
things and then there were bombs planted
in manhattan and jersey city and i said
okay maybe i should move a little bit
further away
then we you know i end up going to south
jersey i see the riots the right the
black lives matter rights the george
floyd riots and i said yeah well we're
on the other side of the river from
philly so we're fine then i heard the
helicopters and they started coming into
the suburbs the protests the riots and i
was like they crossed the bridge
you know what i'm not gonna sit around
to wait and find out where the
escalation leads to and so we ultimately
end up going out to the west virginia
you know we're in the harpers ferry area
which is not the middle of nowhere mind
you it's like an hour from the airport
but i'm still thinking like we need
space
we need to have our own water source
because
the world may not be ending i don't know
but the point is i want to just make
sure that when whatever ends up
happening be it a disaster or crisis or
something in the united states i have
taken responsibility for myself because
the worst case scenario is we got a
great place
we got trees we got deer walking around
we it's beautiful it's fresh air we have
our own well and you know what maybe uh
it's it's good to prepare for some kind
of chaos that may ensue maybe it will
never happen well the worst case
scenario is fresh air and clean water
how about that
i don't know what you're thinking
are you you know about cities i think
look
people have to make individual decisions
individual choices i think one of the
things that people have to do is to get
sources of information and check them
out verify them but much of what you're
being told is just not accurate 30 days
later changes 60 days later changes you
were told this inflation's in transitory
it's just not because asset classes
assets and by the way people are putting
money into commodities food prices are
going up this is
the most massive unfair tax for
working-class people and you're going to
see a revolt that's why biden's handling
the economy is down now into the 40s and
sometimes in the 30s depending on who
the demographic by the way for the other
day an economist poll not the war room
and not tim poole the economist yougov
poll
had the crosstabs which by the way most
of these polls today do not put out the
crosstabs because they don't want to see
how bad when you get into the details
the economist did 250 pages steve cortez
and uh and raheem kassam went through it
and they had in the in
the span
looking at hispanics
biden's handling the economy excellent
zero point
zero first time i've ever seen a double
odd in a in a pod usually you get
something
0.0 excellent okay people are wising up
to it because they see the reality of
their lives and all you have to do to
think about these experts think about
what they told you about the economy
think of what they've told you about
what's happening on the southern border
think what they've told you about the
vaccines think of what they told you
about the ccp virus in the origins of
this virus in wuhan
think about that think about every day
that it's all a nutcase conspiracy
theory and then you get more information
and all sudden it's not okay think about
this war think of what you were told
about afghanistan think about think
about what you were told about the
american citizens left there just think
about what you're told and then later
what you find out to be right and it's
not marginal enough people can make
mistakes it's the exact opposite of what
you were told don't you remember or i
don't know if you can actually remember
the feeling of being totally
disassociated from politics and and and
what was going on and you just watched
football you went to the bar and you had
pizza wasn't that that warm fuzzy
feeling where you'd wake up and just do
your routine
it's all gone isn't it it's a fourth
turning that's that's that's a
pre-fourth time this is what a fourth
turning is we're in the maelstrom right
now we're in the maelstrom and the whole
watching football and kind of living in
in a haze of glory we were on the back
of slaves we were living off the back of
slaves the whole time we just didn't
know but it's the exactly it's the
ignorance you were you you're basking in
the bliss of ignorance and more and more
that's what they want you to be right
remember
most of what's happened this is what's
so powerful i want to go back to the
apes and why they hate the apes so much
what are the apes doing this so bad
they're buying american companies and
holding the stocks
okay they're they're racist they're
nativists they're they're they're
they're market manipulators they're
everything the press beats on these
people all day you know why
because they're crowdsourcing knowledge
they want you to be an idiot they want
you to look at the pro wrestling and
think about a second all the major
events that have really happened 911 the
war in iraq the financial implosion in
2008 the the market these things
how at the time
that you go back and look at what's
covered on cable tv it's all pro
wrestling in the foreground they want
you distracted not just with
entertainment but even the stuff they
say is serious politics is all pro
wrestling it doesn't matter
where the power things that's what this
bloomberg article we're gonna get read
it 838 million dollars an hour okay four
trillion dollars and haven't even
started and it's not going to get
reversed unless you unless you throw
down hard and reverse it you ever hear
about the debt ceiling they don't want
you know about that they don't want you
know that you have the power to say no
they want you to be an idiot did you
know the u.s is liquidating its assets
to try and cover costs because of the
debt ceiling okay we talked about okay
the debt ceiling we're the only show i
think to pick up even the business
president
when yellen remember she's the only
person i believe to be chairman of the
federal reserve and secretary of the
treasury okay so in those circles she's
very highly regarded she gives testimony
right before fourth of july and says oh
by the way you know on july 31st the
debts we hit the debt ceiling and we
will default on government securities on
august 15th i go oh my god this guy we
will default last time i looked it means
you're bankrupt okay
and you you see there that
and they here's the games they play and
this is what the unit party plays
she's got to shuffle around they go
through the the 31st and nothing no
increase their debt ceiling and what are
they doing they're playing three-card
money right they're taking money from
social security they're not putting
money into government pensions they're
doing they're going out and getting
tomato cans in the back of the federal
reserve where's the cash no they're
doing everything they can do
every and this remember these are the
these are your betters
these are the people that think you're
an idiot and treat you like an idiot
these are supposed to be the geniuses
this is all the mckinsey consultant booz
allen they went to the best law schools
the best business schools they're your
betters okay you're better as goddess
afghanistan and the deplorables are over
in arlington national cemetery okay your
bettors are sitting there on the on the
think tanks and on msnbc and they're
giving these proclamations and the
deplorables kids are on those planes
going in there in to 6 500 to try to
save american citizens and they're the
ones on the receiving ends of the
afghani kids are being tossed them over
barbed wire okay
that's the same thing here your bettors
now they're running around getting cash
out of the tomato cans in the back of
the federal reserve to kick the can down
the road till they get back from
vacation they can't handle it in august
august is recess we're coming back after
september 20th then they're gonna have
this false deadline of october 1st and
here's the beauty of it it's going to be
your fault
you're the deplorables oh my gosh you're
going to blow up the capital markets the
debt markets we're going to default on
securities you're the problem you're the
problem they're not the problem how do
you get us in here 28 trillion dollars
and now they're talking about another 6
trillion and there's going to be a 6
tree on top of that on top of that
here's why as long as they can keep
printing and the only way they can keep
printing the full faith and credit of
the united states government is you it's
not them it's you
on your back
okay because you're gonna owe it back on
your back they're gonna keep printing
and printing printing and zero interest
rates the asset classes keep going and
who owns the assets they do they own the
real estate they own the stocks you own
nothing
fifty percent of the american people
can't put four hundred dollars in cash
together
cash together for an emergency
you're two paychecks away from oblivion
you don't own anything and you're not
going to own anything this is the system
that has i'm a capitalist this system
has to be dismantled and it can be
dismantled by the american people if we
act today do you think that the american
people are looking at a future much like
how the how the the chinese citizens
live where you're effectively doing
slave labor for for trash prices
tim poole you can't say what we want to
say on here
because you could be taken off by social
media oligarchs let's be brutally frank
that's right if you and i had the real
conversation that you want to have here
and you're smart enough and your staff
smart enough that's not the conversation
totally okay why
because the the social media oligarchs
they have the ability to take off a
sitting president and shut him up that's
why it's more powerful said this he told
me years ago he said social media is
more powerful than nuclear weapons like
what are you talking about he goes
nuclear weapons if if if if beijing
launches one to you you're gonna launch
two back and they'll stop
social media they can shut down anybody
including a commander-in-chief and
that's what they did they're told
they'll shut you down if you get out of
line with the social credit scores what
do you think the vaccine passports are
the vaccine mandates is your first
social credit score right you can't go
in a restaurant and eat and watch in new
york city you can't get on an airplane
you can't go you can't go where you want
in this country there's no freedom
social credit score this is state
capitalism and authoritarianism and it's
come here today in this country we were
talking with ben stewart about the
fourth turning
and one of the ideas of the fourth
turning is that the mo in every fourth
turning the most powerful weapons
available at the time will be used in
the conflict yes and i said that's not
nuclear weapons it's social media boom
the ability so i've long talked about
this she knows that that's why jack ma
is looking for a job right now right he
cut him right off at that time why
why why do we go to war why why was why
was violence used they were trying to
gain control of something they wanted
something they would take it or they
hate it you know there's often
ideological things but a lot of war is
resources i mean i think it's funny how
many people died about human history to
make food taste better for instance you
know all the spices and the trades and
everything that that you know how many
empires were built on that right right
right
but what happens when you no longer need
to use coerc physical or kinetic force
to command someone to your will well why
expend the energy cost when you can
instead
perhaps pay people 50 cents to post
propaganda in their free time exactly
because it's cyber it's cyber and
information warfare just like economic
warfare kinetic warfare is the most is
the most inefficient right you only do
kinetic warfare and when you have
overwhelming odds but i think we're
sliding to kinetic war because they
think we're weak but you're right the
biggest power is information cyber
you can if you can convince the enemy
nation to lay down their arms and wave
to you and cheer as you enter then you
don't need to waste money on on kinetic
weapons and if you can convince the
populist to pay you a percentage of
their income then you don't have to make
them slaves because they're already
you're already making money you've pers
you you've you've fractionalized the
slavery instead of having one free
person who's running a business and one
slave make them all that's 40 by the way
this is what wall street does today
let's if you take this is the scam of
money managers uh i don't think there's
any money managers over time that have
outperformed s p 400 that's why all
these uh
instruments came up you can just
basically buy the market as a tracker
stock because they haven't over
performed just buying the market and how
the american economy grows and how
stocks relate to that yet your pension
fund money and that's every nurse every
cop
every uh every union member or people
your your money is institutional money
is managed the wall street guys get 20
they get a fee of one or two percent on
assets under management and when you're
talking billions that's real money
that's how they get the house and the
hamptons and the big parties but they
get 20 of the ops off your money and
here's what they did with that they ship
the jobs to china
they ship the jobs to time on your
nickel the greek tragedy part of this
is that working-class people of both
political persuasions
it's
you paid for it all your taxes
and your pension funds are what paid for
this whole thing the whole thing you
have
the ultimate power all power resides
with working-class people in this
country and that's the thing they don't
want you to know because you have the
power it's your money i it's your money
and you could throw these bums out and
that's why they put the pro wrestling to
divide you in the foreground because
they don't want to talk about the for
the bloomberg article today they don't
really want to walk through what's in
these six trillion dollars of spending
it's a 2700 page bill has anybody
explained that bill to you wow has
anybody sat there and said let me take
an hour and walk you through where 1.25
trillion dollars that you and your kids
are gonna pay back let's let's at least
have enough respect for you that will
explain to you no you will not see that
anywhere because they're never going to
do it you know why they understand an
informed electorate is informed consent
right they don't want that they want you
to be
they want you to be distracted by the
bread and circuses on one level of pop
entertainment but also when you get into
politics or it's cable news it's all pro
wrestling it's not the real it's not the
thing itself if it's a thing itself we
wouldn't have these kind of issues that
pop up out of nowhere thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you